[MUSIC]
Andy, welcome back to the GSB.
>> Thanks for having me.
>> It is such an honor,
to be sharing the stage with you.
Your story of founding Bonobos,
from launching the company here at
the GSB in 2007,
to selling it ten years later for
$310 million, is truly inspiring.
I'm so excited to dive into all of
this today.
But before we begin,
I wanted to introduce Bonobos to
those of you who may not be
as familiar with the product.
So, in a view from the top first,
let the fashion show begin.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> [LAUGH]
[MUSIC]
>> On your left, you have Justin in
Italian stretch chinos.
On your right, John Henry Styles
in original stretch washed chinos.
[MUSIC]
>> [APPLAUSE] >> On your left,
we have Diego Ramirez in original
stretch washed chinos.
On your right,
James Underwood in stretch washed
chino 2.0.
>> My God.
[MUSIC]
>> [APPLAUSE] >> On your left,
we have Asha Rod Gupta in yarn dye
stretch chinos, and
Mike Peng in flint straight chinos.
>> Amazing.
>> [APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC]
>> On your left,
we have Olamide Olaniyan,
on your right Jonathan Wakins,
in original stretch washed chinos.
>> [APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC]
>> On your left,
Sunny Stevens in the stretch
weekday worrior dress pants.
And Logan Randolph with the Bonobos
light washed jeans.
>> [LAUGH]
[MUSIC]
>> [APPLAUSE] >> Last but not least
on your, left John Gilhuly in
stretch weekday warriors, and
Joe Bateman with the stretch washed
Chino 2.0 >> [APPLAUSE]
>> [LAUGH] >> Please give a big
hand for our models.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Amazing.
>> I'm sure you've seen, and
been a part of quite a few fashion
shows how- >> Not like that.
Not like that.
>> Me either.
Well, Andy,
many people know you for
the pants that we just saw, and
if they didn't before, they do now.
But not many people know about what
you refer to as your ghost story.
I'd like to read a powerful excerpt
from your book Burn Rate,
if that's okay with you.
>> That sounds good.
>> Okay, [LAUGH] thank you.
In 2016, on the precipice of
selling Bonobos,
the startup I'd been building for
the previous nine years.
I flew into a manic spiral, and
was hospitalized for a week, in the
psych ward at Bellevue in New York.
When I was discharged, I was met by
NYPD officers, who took me to jail,
where I was charged with felony,
and misdemeanor assault.
>> Good cliffhanger.
>> [LAUGH] Thank you.
Not many successful business
leaders talk about their struggle
with mental health.
So, first of all, thank you for
being so open, and doing so.
We'll spend a good portion of the
interview later discussing this.
But every story has a beginning,
so, let's start with yours.
>> Yeah, sounds good.
>> You grew up in the Midwest,
the son of a US History teacher,
and an ultrasound tech.
Tell us a bit more about your
upbringing, and
how it influenced you.
>> Yeah, well, it's funny because
the editor, and my agent,
basically said, we need a chapter
at the beginning of your book about
your upbringing.
And my initial reaction was,
there's nothing interesting about
my upbringing.
I hadn't really thought of
anything, that unique about it.
And then as I got to work on that,
I was like,
there's some stuff here.
My mom's a Indian immigrant,
born in a refugee town,
all the way from Rawalpindi,
Pakistan, to New Delhi, India,
at the time of the partition.
Somewhere between one and two
million were killed, at a time when
14 million people were displaced.
So, her origin story is in
the midst of that strife.
Settled in New Delhi,
came to the US when she was 20.
Her father grew ill from emphysema.
He was the only one
who was a financial means.
So, it was financially
extremely stressful, and
her mother was a child bride.
So, promised to be married at about
10 or 11, married by 12 or 13, two
miscarriages as a teenager, then
two children who died in infancy.
And then seven children,
the middle of him was my mom.
And my mom's oldest sister,
my mossy, delivered me,
she became an OBGYN.
And so, if you ever had this
dynamic in your family where you
have an aunt who can say to you,
I put you in this world,
I can take you out of it.
>> [LAUGH] >> Being sassy.
So, that was a bit on my mom's
family.
And my dad's family were kind of
classic Scandinavian Midwesterners.
So, Danish, Swedish, Norwegian,
all of that.
And so,
I grew up in a biracial household.
And I think,
maybe the most interesting part
of that in retrospect for
me is how different the cultures
were around communication.
And so,
in my dad's family, you don't talk
about small conflicts, those bubble
up and become big conflicts.
And so, eventually,
you don't speak at all.
Very tragically he doesn't speak to
either of his living siblings.
On my mom's side of the family,
you say exactly what you think,
to everyone except the person that
you're thinking about.
>> [LAUGH] >> So,
all the information gets around,
but with no conflict.
My mom's a little
different with us.
And fast forward to later, now I'm
married to a Brazilian Jew, who's
a descendant of the Brazilian, and
New York City Jews.
And you say exactly what you think,
in real time to everyone, except to
the person that you thinking about.
Such that the first
time I had dinner with my now wife,
and mother-in-law,
either my Scandinavian side, or
my Indian side was in the bathroom
dry heaving.
And being like,
I can't be a part of this family.
But in truth was that might have
been a family coming together,
versus falling apart.
So, this is somewhat,
some of the origin story for
my family.
And I think the other piece of
it is my sister.
I have an incredibly loving older
sister.
In Hindi, we call her Didi.
We have a business together now,
which actually is
a really bad idea.
We'll talk about friendship and
business, and family and business.
In truth, it's brought us much
closer together,
because we have more time to spend,
but it also it's challenging.
Family and business is challenging,
just as friendship and
business is challenging.
>> Well, Andy,
we have something in common.
My mom also tells me that she
brought me into this world,
and she can take me out.
So, I've heard that as well.
But you grew up in the Midwest, and
you ended up leaving and
coming to the GSB.
Here in 2005 is where the idea for
Bonobos was born.
>> Yeah. >> Your roommate
in Schwab, Brian Spaly,
ended up becoming your co-founder.
>> Yeah.
>> Take us back to those early
days of Bonobos on campus.
>> Yeah. >> And why men's pants?
>> Yeah, so, it was inverted,
actually.
Brian was the founder of Bonobos,
and I became his co-founder.
And the way that it went down
is this.
Brian came in, and felt like
there's this one problem that he
had which is his pants didn't fit.
And so he did one of these
projects, I can't remember what
they're called, G 300.
He used to be call them
the 300 project.
And he went out, and he got this
survey with all of our classmates.
And the basic insights were Guys
wear jeans because khaki pants and
wool pants don't fit that well.
So that was
like insight number one.
And insight number two was,
guys don't like shopping in stores.
And then insight number three was
that J Crew and Banana Republic
were the two main places.
So his view about men's pants
was very specific, which is that if
the pants fit around your thighs
and your butt, they were probably
too tight in the waist.
So that when you sat down,
you were really uncomfortable
back in an era where you had to
wear pants to work, right?
And so then as soon as you got
home, you threw your jeans on, and
your weekend going out was denim.
And the thing that happened in
premium denim in the 90s was there
was stretch that was added to
the fabric,
which had never happened before.
So, step one was Brian added
stretch to khaki pants and
wool pants, which was not a massive
thing at the time.
The other insight that Brian had
was that pants are kind of boring.
And so he developed this contrast
liner that would peek through
the back pockets.
They would kind of
create a conversation, they called
it conversational prints in a very
specific place, and he started just
selling pants to our classmates.
So he found a factory in
San Francisco and he found
a pattern maker in San Francisco,
part of the last dying vestige of
the fashion industry here.
And he brought pants that he had
worn where he would buy like a size
34 that fit his thighs and
then tailor it into a 32,
which is a $80 alteration, probably
that no one here has ever done,
because you have Bonobos, right?
And Bonobos pants are made with
that contour,
like curved waistband.
So then he drove to LA, he bought
a bunch of fabric, he picked
a really cool pinwale corduroy,
really thin, really lightweight,
it had great stretch.
Which is kind of perfect for
Northern California because it's
cool in the morning and then it
kind of heats up during the day.
And he just started selling them to
our classmates for $100.
And it was like, well, one person
was wearing them, then five and
then at some point, half of our
classmates were buying pants.
We did a pants party at our house,
I don't know if anyone has his
house on El Camino Real,
used to call the white house,
anyone live there?
>> It's still around today.
>> It's still around, yeah.
So Brain tried to rebrand it to
Pleasure Town which didn't
[INAUDIBLE], but then it went back
to the white house.
Brian is an eccentric character and
hopefully many of you will meet him
in MGE or have met him.
And we had a pants party
where people were playing whatever
games and long games, and
we sold $16,000 of pants that day.
And so if you ever have a product
where you sell that much and
it's a legal product.
>> [LAUGH] >> You might be on to
something.
>> And you definitely were,
that is incredible to sell $16,000
worth of pants in one day.
After the GSB, you decide to work
on Bonobo's full time, while Brian
decides to take a job in PE and
work on Bonobos on nights and
weekends.
What gave you that conviction?
I know so many of us entrepreneurs
and aspiring entrepreneurs
are wondering whether or not we
should take that leap of faith.
>> I went on a GSB service trip to
East Africa and it was like 12 or
13, do you have these service
learning trips still?
And we did a homestay for
two nights, and I lived with a guy
named Stanley and his wife and
two kids.
And it was a clay brick house
without running water.
They prepared a wonderful meal,
of course, and
then there was a big bucket,
where you dump it over your head.
And generally it's cold water,
which is like the ice bucket
challenge.
And of course, they found a way to
heat it, which was wonderful and
it's also like an outhouse where
you shower or close by.
And then I came back to
the white house,
the one here in El Camino Real.
And my bathroom you had to walk
outside to get to, and it had two
showerheads, which is plush,
and I turned them on and
the hot water hit me.
And I had this moment where I was
like, we do not actually take that
much risk.
The way that we define it in the US
for people in the cohort in this
room, it's actually not risky to
start a company.
It's an insult to people whose
lives are actually risky to think
of it as risk in similar terms, and
I don't mean
that in a judgmental way.
Many of us have reasons,
there are medical cost reasons and
children, and there are things to
be thoughtful of, but in terms of
having our future net present value
is in pretty good shape.
And so if you redefine the risk of
not doing something that you love,
and that I think is a spiritual
risk rather than a financial risk.
And so that trip really changed me.
And I felt like okay, even though I
have $3,000 in the bank and
182,000 of debt, maybe a third of
which was elective,
just having fun and traveling.
I'm probably not going to starve
one day.
And with that perspective,
I was like, okay,
then what can we go do?
And I had no good idea of my own,
so I thought, okay,
I'll just steal Brian's idea.
>> [LAUGH] Worked out well.
That is a helpful way of reframe
around risk and that reframe
allowed you to take the leap of
faith to move to New York, and
to work on Bonobos.
At the time, you were truly
a pioneer building a direct
consumer digitally native brand.
Just to take everyone back to 2007,
Amazon was irrelevant in fashion.
People thought e-commerce was
going to be an afterthought.
And if you were a fashion brand not
selling through the likes
of Barneys and Bloomingdale's,
you were doomed to fail.
So Andy,
how did you have this aha moment to
build a digitally native brand and
how did you convince others?
>> Well, first, and what is it?
Great entrepreneurs are just
thieves.
And then second,
the future is here,
it's just not evenly distributed.
So if you want to build the future,
don't look to the future,
look to something that's
in the corner in the present.
And then kind of past is prologue,
which is that more or
less we're the same species last
200,000 years.
So there's probably something in
history that might alert you to
what was coming.
For that third thing for me it was
that I'd worked at Land's End as
a second year being in AC.
Has anyone spent a couple of
winters in Dodgeville, Wisconsin?
It's cold, there's not a lot to
do other than just work.
And I got to see this storied
catalog retailer that didn't have
stores.
And I remember one day touring
the call center and
seeing all the notes from customers
that had been mailed in.
And there was a note from a woman
that said, dear Elizabeth, thank
you so much for calling me to wake
me up the morning of my wedding.
My mom was a mess, my bridesmaids
were on the sleep end.
You're the best, Carolyn.
And I was like,
the paradox of retail is that by
not having brick and
mortar stores and going direct, and
this was the catalog innovation,
you can actually build a better
customer service relationship.
And then in terms of what was
happening in the present that was
in the corner, there was this
company called Zappos.
And an entrepreneur named Tony Shea
and backed by Sequoia.
And it was like, you know startups
how there's little rumors, you
don't know exactly what's going on,
you see that they exist.
And they were selling shoes.
And everyone at the time, this was
a time where e-commerce people were
selling cars on eBay Motors.
But it was like, well,
you're never going to sell shoes
because you gotta try them on.
Wait, don't you have to drive
the car?
But Tony had free returns both
ways, 365 day return policy, and
a really spirited service team who
were core to the company culture,
right?
And that's obviously what
Delivering Happiness is about
the book, and the irony of that
title relative to Tony's fate,
well, I guess we'll get to that
type of conversation later.
So I was like, well, if you can
sell an existing soft goods product
footwear, then presumably you can
clothing, and why can't you build
your own brand, right?
And then I kind of looked at
the history of the Gap which used
to sell Levi's jeans and records.
And then an entrepreneur named
Mickey Drexler came in and said,
well, the margins on Levi's jeans
are here,
why don't we make Gap jeans?
We would get another 20% margins.
Well so, for you're a retailer with
stores you're not a brand.
But he said no,
let's vertically integrate that.
And now everything from you
pick it, right?
From IKEA to Zara,
it's all vertical now
because of that margin trade.
So I took those three ideas and
put them together, and then I went
out to pitch people on the concept,
and everyone said no.
And that made me really feisty.
>> [LAUGH] >> And
also as a part of innovation which
is that it's gotta be contrarian at
the time.
>> Well,
you were really onto something and
building this direct to consumer
brand.
On the surface it seems like things
are going well, this is 2007, 2008.
But internally, if you look under
the hood of Bonobos,
you were dealing with quite a bit
of friction with your co-founder,
Brian Staley, as you've alluded to.
So can you take us back to that
time in the life of Bonobos and
what happened there?
>> Well, I blamed
everything on him.
>> [LAUGH] >> Right, it's easy in
life, I think to see someone else
as the problem in your life story.
And then if you get to my age or
beyond, 43 now, it's some point,
hopefully, you realize that you
are the problem in your life story.
And it's a little bit debilitating
to take that on, but
it's also very freeing because then
you don't have to stand in judgment
of others in the same way.
And you also have agency to fix it,
if you don't need someone else
to change.
But in 2008 and
9, I was 28, 29 years old, and I
had these issues with conflict that
I described.
I wasn't able to verbalize
conflict and have really
difficult conversations with
Brian because he was my friend.
And now there's this whole school
of radical candor that talks about,
if you're high on caring but
low on conflict, you're in a bucket
that they call ruinous empathy.
I was like, that's me,
I'm the ruinous empathy person.
And the problem with
ruinous empathy is, in theory,
you care about other people, but
you care about them so
much that you never actually tell
them the truth, right?
Which is not that caring.
And so we ended up in a place where
my anger was building and
building towards Brian for
perceived slights.
My stresses at the company as we
hired more people and
raise more money we're going up,
and I remember having a call with
one of the professors at the GSB.
The only reason Bonobos exists
outside of Brian's innovation, from
a financial standpoint, is that two
professors back the company,
Joe Peterson and Andy Ratcliffe.
And I called Andy one day and
I sent him our P&L.
And I was like, Brian is got,
we have a major inventory problem.
We designed this swimsuits thing,
it's not working, and Andy
literally on the call was like, no,
the problem on your
PL is your OpEx.
It's your operating expenses,
which is actually what Brian was,
I felt criticizing me for, but
it wasn't necessarily criticism it
was challenge, because he's like
we're hiring too many people.
And I was convinced that we had to
bring on a great VP of engineering
from Zappos, and
we had to build this tech company.
And Brian was, it's kind of a pants
company, and I was like, well,
it's a tech company that sells
pants >> [LAUGH] >> And so we had
all these vectors of conflict, but
we were unable to resolve it,
I think in retrospect,
due to my limitations.
And Brian's not perfect of course,
but in our relationship
the friendship was ultimately
sublimated to the business
discussion, which is
the business conversations,
which is also common.
So I woke up at some point dealing
with a lot of depression.
I really disliked Brian.
I wasn't so happy with myself and
that led to a co-founder divorce
that happened two years after
the company's formation.
>> Yeah, given the conflict you
described and that leading
to the co-founder split,
is there any advice you would give
to GSB students in terms of
thinking through how not only to
select a co-founder, but
also safeguards to put in place in
the case of co-founder divorce?
>> Yeah, so I think when it comes
to selecting GSB co-founders,
don't.
>> [LAUGH] >> But if you insist,
and I do think there's something
to be explored, which is,
that the right co-founder for your
company might be at Stanford but
might not be a GSB student, someone
from another school who brings an
entirely complementary skill set.
In very likely you're going to be
the CEO of that company which is
cool because CEO is a fun job, and
you won't have the same kind of
complimentary skill sets.
If you do exist on founding
a company with a Stanford, GSB
classmate, and I wouldn't do it,
I wouldn't do life any other way.
There was no way for
me to access what became my life
without partnering with Brian,
because he was the product
innovator and the product genius.
It's worth really thinking about
what you're going to do
differently.
Not at time zero, because
that's pretty straightforward, but
like four years later, right?
So once the company has 40 people,
how's it going to work?
Because when everyone's in a room,
it's kind of okay if you have two
people running the company, but
once you have 40 people,
it's extremely difficult,
the co-CEO thing.
I love Ben Horowitz's comment on
co-CEOs when he meets them,
which is let me get this straight.
It's more important to optimize for
your egos than it is for
having a clear decision maker at
the company, and
it's a tough one to respond to.
Some people do pull it off,
friends of mine, Dave and
Neil at Warby Parker have,
it's remarkable.
But I would hope that someone at
the GSB will write a case about how
they did it, because it's so rare.
And it's so much more often
the case that there is someone that
leaves before the other person, and
that that leaving has acrimony
attached to it.
And I would love to teach a case on
class on co-founder divorce,
because there's a bunch from
the GSB, the founders of StubHub
didn't speak for a decade.
There were founders from my class
who had Adventure Together,
who were married and
literally got divorced.
So I think it's important to,
if you're going to do it,
recognize that you are putting
the friendship to rest.
The friendship ends the day
that you go into business together,
because the partnership
eclipses it.
>> Those are good considerations
and great advice.
Also I'm sure we would love to have
you and come back to the GSP and
teach that class.
Brian Spaly does end up going to
sell Trunk Club to Nordstrom, so
he does have a successful exit of
his own.
But, Andy, now it's 2009,
you're alone at the helm of Bonobos
as the sole remaining co-founder
and CEO.
Over the course of the next eight
or nine years you are constantly
innovating and trying to figure out
how to grow the brand.
Whether that's
introducing new product categories,
figuring out if you should utilize
e-commerce in different ways.
And then continually innovating,
you end up actually,
revolutionizing the brick and
mortar shopping experience with
Bonobos guide shops.
So can you tell us a bit about how
you were able to innovate and
constantly see gaps that others
couldn't at the time?
>> Yeah, I love startups because
they're a collision of fantasy and
reality.
And there's many genres of human
work where you develop ideas and
you get to get really passionate
about those ideas.
There are a few where those ideas
are tested and really have
interrogated and evaluated on a sub
five year timeframe.
And one of the most humbling things
about being an entrepreneur is that
you certainly have enough vision at
the beginning to start something,
if it exists, you have done that.
But the false conclusion that you
might reach is that you're going to
be able to do that again and again.
And so you might convince yourself
that you're really good at vision.
And the truth might be that you
were really good at the beginning.
And so what I learned was
the innovations that were the most
profound were not ones that I
envisioned, but
ones that I noticed.
And so ust to talk about the
stories, we had two fitting rooms
that we fabricated in New Jersey,
that were ostensibly to take around
and do different pants parties.
And one night we rented out a bar
and we invited our best customers
and it took 18 people on our team
to move these fitting rooms.
And it was a massive effort and
we had a bar tab and
everyone drank a lot and
we sold like eight pairs of pants.
So I was like, well,
that wasn't great.
The traveling fitting rooms concept
is not going to be our next thing.
And so they sat in our lobby
collecting dust.
And then when we were moving from
product one to product two,
from pants to button down shirts.
Thinking about how to eliminate
some of the we called it
billowing muffin top of the shirt,
which you saw none of
the gentlemen who walked out.
[LAUGH] It was a very tailored
look.
We wanted customers to come in and
try it on.
And so we called it the dress
shirt alpha.
We put it out on Twitter and
Facebook, was not reviled company
at the time.
And people came in and
they tried it on and
they were like, your dress shirts
suck, but can we buy some pants?
And we're like,
well we don't sell any pants here.
And it turned into this thing of
well can we just try ons and pants.
And so we had a fit run and
navy of every size.
And then they would say,
can we see the other colors?
And they started transacting and
it would be like, can we buy some?
And it was like, well,
we can just do an e-commerce
transaction in person.
And so at the time we were about
a $10 million business and
we started doing a million of sales
out of our lobby unintentionally.
And I remember we had recruited
a merchant from J Crew.
Because after Brian left I had to
quickly fill the Brian sized
hole at the company, which was
merchandising, design, sourcing,
and production, supply chain.
The creative eye was hard.
That was the hardest part about
that year.
And our VP of merchandising, a guy
named Brad Andrews, who's now up at
Nike, remarkable person, was I
kind of like what's going on inside
this little part of our lobby.
And so then we said why don't we
try to experiment with putting
that at street level?
And the unit economics
were really interesting because we
didn't have to stock the store and
having sold watches at
Marshall Fields growing up.
And worked at Abercrombie and
Fitch on the night shift this was
20 years before the documentary, so
don't judge me.
But Abercrombie and
Fitch sweaters when I was at
Northwestern were the rage and they
cost $72, I still remember this,
which I couldn't afford.
So I was like I will
go fold sweaters at night, so
I can pretend I'm rich like
my classmates at Northwestern.
Very sad.
And folding sweaters on the night
shift kind of sucks, right?
Sweater after sweater,
there's like the board you put in.
And I remember thinking if we could
build a store where no one's doing
that, what could we put in instead
of the inventory management.
We can put in one to one service,
which we turned into calling it
the guides.
And we opened 30 great stores, and
then we opened 30 stores where
we spent too much money and
didn't need incremental doors in
the markets.
But that was the second innovation
in the history of the company after
the selling pants online
innovation.
>> Well these innovations helped
you grow up a novice
to a company that was doing over
$100 million in revenue, its 2016
the world's largest company comes
knocking on your door.
>> Yeah. >> And
they end up acquiring bonobos for
$310 million.
Many people saw these headlines and
were wondering how this acquisition
might affect the Bonobos brand.
So can you tell us a bit about
why an acquisition and
an acquisition by Walmart was
the right path for Bonobos?
>> Yeah, so
we were right on the cusp of doing
a deal with a private equity fund.
That's really good and consumer and
there's two of those globally.
And that was a joke, guys.
>> [LAUGH] >> But it's hard when
you start a company, it's hard to
identify private equity investors
who you want to work for.
It's a big change and so we figured
out a way to barely work for them,
which is they were going to buy
a 40% stake in the company.
We were going to maintain
the majority as existing investors,
and they made a really good offer.
And I went out to dinner at
a restaurant called Auto with
my CFO and our general counsel,
the founder of the firm and
the partner that worked on it.
And they gave me the term sheet at
dinner, and I walked home,
which was a few blocks to where
Manuel and I shared an apartment on
Ninth Street.
They'd given a bottle of wine as
a gift and I was fumbling with
the keys because I was about to
show my wife a $300 million offer.
And as I was fumbling I dropped
the offer and the bottle of wine
at the same time.
And there was this guy named Newton
who said that two things will drop
at the same rate regardless of size
and so the bottle of wine exploded
on the offer.
And so I walked in with
an offer that was dripping red.
And I was like, Manuel,
I've got the blood money.
>> [LAUGH] >> We're selling out.
And during that process and
in truth I really did like these
people and I felt like they got it.
They had this thing they needed
to do, which is they needed to put
their capital ahead of everyone
else's in the preference stack.
And I was like,
you guys just got to the party.
Why are you in the first in line?
And so we were messing around for
weeks and weeks and
then I heard from someone hey,
you should talk to Mark Laurie.
Mark had founded diapers.com and
sold it to Amazon,
then he founded something
called jet and it was wild.
He came out of Amazon and was like,
we're going to beat Amazon.
And the rumor was that he was
burning 20 million a month in cash.
And then he sold the company to
Walmart for 3 billion which was
the only buyer on planet earth.
So who does that?.
And I walked into meet Mark
in Hoboken and he
was wearing a Vineyard Vines shirt.
And I was like, I didn't walk in
here in an f'ing Amazon t-shirt.
He didn't care that much about
the meeting, but
then we sat down and we mind melded
on this concept that the future of
commerce might look a little
bit like the history of video.
Which is that initially the big
platforms were streaming other
people's movies and shows, and
eventually that was a race to
the bottom on price, and so they
would need to develop their own.
Content to win.
And when Netflix launched House of
Cards and Orange is the New Black,
if you go back and look at it,
their share price took a hit
because Wall Street was like,
what are you trying to do to,
become HBO?
And in fact, that turned out
to be an astute move.
So Mark and I that I would come in
and run this new digital private
brand group at Walmart.
And he said you gotta meet Doug.
And I went down to Soho one night
and met this Doug McMillon,
unassuming guy, for dinner
with Mark, and he, how do I put it?
I came out of the dinner being
like, it would be a privilege to
work for this individual.
I fell in professional love, and
I'm still in professional love with
Doug McMillon.
He's the best leader I've ever seen
in action, and we should get him up
in this chair at some point.
And I was like, wow,
it would be really cool to see this
Walmart-Amazon battle play out
with not a front row seat, but
a second or third row seat.
>> Well, it's quite impressive that
you became a part of the digital
transformation of the Fortune one
company.
And this obviously was such a big
milestone in the life of bonobos.
And all throughout you growing and
scaling the company, you internally
are dealing with so much.
So I want to pivot now and
talk a bit about your bipolar
disorder diagnosis.
Tell us more about not only
the diagnosis in college, but
also your initial reaction.
>> Yeah, so I was diagnosed
when I was a senior in college.
I had a few weeks where I kind of
took my partying to the next level.
I was already drinking a lot,
smoking a little bit pot.
But I moved into a bit of ecstasy
and I had my first experience with
psilocybin mushrooms, which for me,
luckily was the last.
A few weeks later,
it was the turn of the millennium,
so it was 1999 to 2000.
And it was a very exciting time,
because there was this Y2K
narrative about how the digital
world was going to melt down.
And then there was this like,
what does the new millennium mean?
And so as I was using substances,
and had really fallen in love
in a really meaningful way for
the first time in my life.
I was watching one night a special
on people who thought that this was
going to be the end of the world,
or that the Messiah was going to
arrive.
And as my mood escalated, at some
point, I realized I was arriving.
I thought that I was
the second coming.
And part of what is so humiliating
about mania is that we have these
messianic grandiose delusions.
And when you come out of it,
you're like everyone now knows that
I have this underlying God complex.
And so it took multiple years later
of therapy for my psychiatrist,
who I affectionately refer to in
the book as Dr.
Z, to make me aware that everyone
actually has a God complex.
And the God complex begins in
infancy, because when you scream,
you get milk, and when you cry,
you get comforted.
This is for
the vast majority of infants,
not everyone, sadly.
And so we begin our lives as all
powerful beings,
and then we slowly part with that
reality year by year.
At the same time as Disney and
Harry Potter incept us with the
possibility that we may be orphans
who turned out to have superpowers.
Which is to say that our popular
culture is built around
the struggling childhood to
superpower thing.
And so most of us discard the idea
that we have superpowers,
should they ever come up.
When you're psychotic, and one of
the things that might help you
understand a person in psychosis,
is that you don't have the ability
to disregard that thought.
The irrational thoughts that you
might have at any point in the day,
the plane hit some turbulence,
we're all going to die, right?
Or that deer, maybe that's my
daughter who passed on, like
the movie with Frances McDormand.
Those kinds of thoughts
are fantastical, and they're not
discarded by a psychotic person.
And so I spent a week as Jesus 2.0,
and it was amazing.
>> [LAUGH] >> It was amazing.
Being the Messiah when manic is so
fun, if you actually believe that's
true.
And then it turns out that you're
actually the biggest liability on
the planet for everyone around you.
So I stopped eating.
I stopped drinking anything,
including water.
I stayed up for, we think,
four nights in a row.
And somehow through,
my friends figuring it out, calling
my parents, my parents bringing
me home, me lecturing my dad on all
kinds of stuff.
My whole theory was that I was
the Messiah and my message, and
some of you may like this message,
is that God is actually a woman.
>> [LAUGH] >> It's like why did
men get all this credit throughout
history when women make life.
And so I was yelling at my dad
about this, and I was like,
all your heroes are white guys.
And my dad was a master,
he just went full Socrates on me,
and was like mm-hm, mm-hm.
And then they called over my aunt,
the one who delivered me, and
my uncle who are both physicians,
and they sat on either
side of me in the back of a car and
took me to hospital.
And that happened to be a hospital
where I had worked growing up and
the hospital where my mom worked,
which just compounded
the humiliation afterwards.
And so when the diagnosing
physician said,
you have bipolar disorder type 1,
I remember thinking, no, I don't,
like, what is that?
Two weeks ago,
I was having fun with my friends,
I don't even know what that means.
And then I went home and I did some
learning and found out that
the suicide attempt rate is 60%,
and the suicide rate is 20%.
So when you're 20, and you're like,
well, there's statistically
a 1 in 5 chance
I'm going to end my own life.
And by the way, this whole mania
thing can come back at any point,
could be two weeks or ten years,
and you might do anything in that
state, like cut off your ear.
It's very hard to take that
diagnosis on as a 20-year-old, and
it's most frequently diagnosed
between 18 and 25.
And so back to
the family norms of communication,
very different families, but
one thing that cultures did have in
common was an abject desire to not
speak about mental health.
And so my diagnosis became a little
bit like fight club, which is, we
don't talk about fight club, right?
We just buried it, and
my friends buried it too.
And so I internalized that as
an unspeakable shame, right,
because what is shame, but
what is unspeakable?
And the amazing thing about
the human mind is you can
actually bury this trauma yourself.
So I became unaware that these
events had transpired, and then in
occasion would remember this thing
that happened to me in college.
I wasn't even aware.
And then I would remember and
have this rising panic and fear.
Wait, what does that mean,
is that true?
And then push it back down.
And I lived that way for 16 years.
And I lived asymptomatic for
the first eight, which lulled us
collectively as a family
into a feeling that perhaps it had
been an inaccurate diagnosis.
And then in bonobos years,
depression kicked in, and
ultimately it came raging back.
>> Wo, and you mentioned it came
raging back.
Can you tell us a bit about
the episode that I described
at the beginning of the interview,
where you find yourself
in Bellevue for a week?
>> Yeah, so
one of the most pernicious things
about mania is that it can be
triggered by positive life events,
having a child, getting married,
let's say selling your company.
In my case, it was falling in love
with Manuela and
coming to the decision that I was
going to ask her to marry me.
And I did it in a very romantic
way, when while manic,
I showed her a picture of the ring,
which is a great reveal, right?
I was so
excited during that time in my life
that I kind of replicated the going
off the rails of Going out a lot,
drinking a lot, not sleeping much.
Sleep quality
is poor if you're drinking a lot.
She left,
she was working and spending
time in Beijing at that moment.
And while she was out I was
just going off the rails,
burning the candle at both ends,
which wasn't terribly uncommon for
me but it was more acute.
And when she came back, I was off.
But she wasn't quite sure how to
process it because while I
had told her that I'd had this
incident in college,
I told her what also was true,
which was that bipolar disorder is
a differential diagnosis, and
people aren't always definitely
sure that that's what it is.
It's both over-diagnosed and
under-diagnosed.
And I had gone to a few mental
health professionals in New York
when I was dealing with acute
depression.
And most people were like,
the company that you're running,
that's a really stressful thing,
and you don't strike me as having
this illness.
And so I had a few people who kind
of dismissed it.
So she wasn't really prepared, and
it got bad that night.
I was laying in bed,
I was howling at the moon.
I was playing Tupac really loud,
and music sounded so good.
And she didn't know what to do, so
she called her mom,
her mom came over.
Her mom lived in New York.
And they were trying to kind of
comfort me and
manage the situation.
And I got up with a start to go to
the bathroom.
And we lived in a little garden
apartment where there
was kind of a low ceiling and
I hit my head on the ceiling and
cracked open and was bleeding, and
it hurt really bad.
Plus with the mania,
you feel more acutely.
And we'd had this fight
with our landlord.
And there was a heating grate that
had rats that could come out of it,
and I hated our landlord.
And so I did something I had wanted
to do for a long time which is
I rip the grade off and threw it.
And then I punched a large glass
window pane and
opened up both of my knuckles here,
and I can still see the scars as
kind of I take it as a healthy
reminder of what's possible.
And then Manuela came to help me,
and I remember seeing the fear in
her eyes.
And my immediate thought was this
is sort of weird, but
I thought she was the alien from
Ex Machina because she kind of is
stunningly beautiful, and smart,
and a little bit robotics sometimes
with her intelligence and logic,
and so I struck her.
And then her mom came out.
And the felony charge was that I
pushed her mom to the ground and
I kicked her.
And they were extremely brave.
Manuela got her mom to
the bathroom, her mom called 911.
Eight New York police officers
showed up within about two minutes.
They pinned me to the ground,
cuffed me, and took me to
the psychiatric emergency room at
Bellevue, where I spent a week
unaware of what had happened.
And as I came down from it,
Manuela came to visit every
day which was incredible,
I noticed that she had a black eye.
And it was about day five or
six and I just said did I hit you?
And she said you're kind of a wuss
and it didn't hurt.
>> [LAUGH] >> And then it was
a noose to the sky of shame to know
that that had happened.
>> Wow, after that episode,
how did you think about your
bipolar disorder diagnosis,
and what do you do today to help to
keep it under control of it?
>> Yeah, so
coming out of the hospital,
walking into handcuffs, the next
six months were like a hell escape.
And it was, was Manuela going to
leave me, was I going to have to
step down from my job,
was there going to be PR about it?
I remember being in
the Fourth Precinct in New York.
A place I never thought I'd be,
it was across the street from my
favorite restaurant,
this Italian restaurant called.
I never even noticed that there,
this isn't sound funny but
a cute police department across
the street.
And now I'm in the cell there,
the arresting
officer is the one booking me.
He took my mug shots and
I said, Officer are these mug shots
going to be online?
And he was like, yeah, but dude,
you're not the founder of Google,
you sell pants.
>> [LAUGH] >> And that was true,
that was true, right?
If I had had a higher public
profile there probably would have
been press because of the mug
shots.
It was under my legal name
Andrew Dan, which is not a thing.
And I was in and out of court, and
there are court reporters but
it wasn't,
it never happened on the PR front.
I was supported by the board.
Ben Wallace stayed with me but
with condition,
which is that I took my medication,
and saw a doctor, and I became
religious about staying healthy.
I started seeing a psychiatrist in
lower Manhattan twice a week for
45 minutes.
I did whatever he said,
medication-wise, and that included
six months of experimentation
where I felt suicidal everyday.
And I also knew, because after the
big highs is a usually a long low.
The big high is fast,
it's like a week, the low that
follows it can be a half a year or
years depending on the kind of
treatment that you have available.
And I had great
treatment available,
which is a fundamental injustice
that we have in our society, which
is that mental health is reimbursed
at a very low rate, and it's hard
to find the right provider.
But I got through that, and so
now I have a pretty robust system
of medication.
I still see that doctor twice
a week, and sleep is so critical,
sleep is foundational, so
I have a sleep report that I send,
screenshot of a Fitbit report,
a WhatsApp group and
it goes every morning.
And so everyone knew yesterday
which is a little bit annoying
because I know my mom worries about
it still, that night before last I
slept four hours and 33 minutes.
And everyone knew I was coming
to give this talk,
which I was excited about.
And so last night was a high
pressure sleep night.
So I was getting dinner,
it was fancy, I treated myself to
dinner at Nobu last night.
And I was at the bar and
I looked down at the Menu and
I saw cocktails that look good.
And then I saw the nonalcoholic
user thing.
>> [LAUGH] >> It's $15 and
I had three, and
then I had a friend text,
he's like you're in town,
do you want to meet up?
And I was like, I so
badly want to meet up and
I was like,
I can't slept four hours,
big day tomorrow,
then I went home and
I took the right medication,
my doctor and I had a plan and
I had an eight hour night.
And I sent it to my family and
my mom was like, good.
>> [LAUGH] >> So it's humbling to
be in this kind of a dynamic, but
I know that transparency with my
loved ones is a critical part of my
health and therefore theirs, so
it's a pretty olympic regimen at
this point.
>> Well, it's great to hear that
you have a process
that helps you today.
And whether you have bipolar
disorder or not,
mental hygiene is so important.
And I know mental health is
the focus of your
newest venture pumpkin pie.
So tell us a little bit
more about that.
>> Yeah, so pumpkin pie started as
an idea to find a husband for
my mother-in-law, who's amazing,
she's amazing.
And she's, how do I put this?
She's very talkative, and
boundaries are not her strong suit.
So she's got a lot to offer and
she's lonely.
I think she'd be okay with
me saying that.
So, we started the company has
an idea of how do we build a dating
app for senior citizens
I had been a founding investor and
board member at Hinge, so
I got to see the social mobile
dating wars play out.
And I remember thinking as I spent
time entertaining the idea
of helping my grandmother,
I should just go with her
on the dating apps.
So I like took over her match
account.
Have you ever dated as
a 75-year-old woman?
>> [LAUGH] >> The guys aren't
the best at writing the profiles.
>> [LAUGH] >> And yet there's so
much knowable at that stage
about someone's life.
All right, when you're 25, so
much of your life stories in
front of you.
When you're 75, there's so
many choices and
experiences you've made.
Have you spent
your professional time whether you
got married or not?
Did you have kids?
It's just amazing amount of newable
information and it's not really
there other than the profile.
So we developed this.
It's a game where you reveal your
personality by opining
on polarizing things.
And then we hired a computer
scientist from this school and
I recruited a GSB friend
to be my co-founder.
>> [LAUGH] >> Some lessons diehard.
>> [LAUGH] >> He's the founder and
CEO of chess.com as his day job, so
he's had an entertaining last
couple of months.
And we built the algorithm in
the app, and
it had zero predictive ability
around romantic relationships.
>> [LAUGH] >> But
the sample group we set
it out to include people who were
platonic friends with each other.
And it was highly predictive of
platonic friendship.
And so that's when we said
maybe we could build Tinder but for
platonic friends.
And the problem we've discovered
with that and
the reason it hasn't been built is
that the two ingredients in
a platonic friendship are mutual
vulnerability in continuous,
ongoing, unplanned interactions.
>> Mm-hm.
>> And so how do you plan off of
an app an unplanned interaction and
that's the conundrum that
we're trying to transcend.
>> We will stay tuned.
Andy, I have one final question for
you before we have
a quick lightning round.
This is a question that
we're asking all of you from
the top speakers this year.
>> Yeah.
>> Principled leadership is
paramount at the GSB.
What do you view as your role and
leading with responsibility to not
just your organization, but
also society at large?
>> Yeah, so I love Ken Chenault,
who ran American Express, one of
the great black CEOs and pioneers,
and he ran MX through many things.
He was phenomenal CEO and
also through 911.
And coming out of 911,
where some 50 American Express
employees perished.
He came out of that at some point
and said that the job of a leader
is just twofold.
It's two bullets, two words each
create hope, define reality.
And I love that.
And I think creating hope and
defining reality are almost
impossible to do at the same time
because reality is scary and bleak.
And then hope is something that we
need to magnetize people to follow
us.
And we need to lead them somewhere
winsome.
And so
I look at where we are socially and
hope is hard at the moment.
Hope is hard from a climate
standpoint, hope is hard from
a justice standpoint, whether
racial gender, sexuality otherwise,
hope is hard from a political
divisiveness standpoint.
There's a lot to not be hopeful
about.
And yet
your job is to be hopeful and to
convince other people to be hopeful
to the people who will be following
you in whatever you do next.
And then your job is also
to not let those people down by not
being realistic about what you're
trying to do.
And doing those things together
it takes a rare human that can do
both of those things and many of
those rare humans are right here.
>> Mm-hm, well, thank you.
That's a great note to end on.
We'll do a quick lightning round
now just in the interest of time.
This is a view from the top
tradition.
So Andy, I'll ask you four
questions and- >> Yeah.
>> Please say whatever comes
to mind first.
>> Okay, I'm ready.
>> All right.
[INAUDIBLE].
>> [LAUGH] Yeah.
So the first one is best piece of
advice ever received.
>> You catch more flies with honey.
>> Nice [LAUGH].
Next time the Cubs will win
the World Series.
>> 2034.
>> Wow, okay?
[SOUND] Most memorable GSB class.
>> Interpersonal dynamics.
>> Yeah, fan favorite [SOUND].
Favorite bonobo is pants print.
>> The Pink Panthers,
before the trademark, shut us down,
>> [LAUGH] >> Wish we had a model
wearing that today.
Andy, you didn't give your talk
here on campus when you're a GSB
student, but thank you so much for
coming back and
sharing your story today.
>> Yeah, thank you.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Thank you so much, Andy.
>> Thank you.
>> Thank you so much.
>> Yeah, [LAUGH].
>> [APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC]